IT COULD BE OUR UNDOING.
THIS IS A PROPAGANDA WAR WITH
HISTORIC LONG-TERM CONSEQUENCES
AND SO FAR, WE ARE LOSING BADLY.
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY REPRESENTS
MISERY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT HEALTH
AUTHORITIES IN THE WEST, AND OF
COURSE, OUR MINDLESS MEDIA,
UNCRITICALLY ACCEPT CHINA’S
HEALTH STATISTICS AND USE THEM
AS A BASIC FOR DECISION-MAKING
HERE?
>> YOU KNOW TUCKER, THE SAME
PEOPLE, THE WASHINGTON ELITES
AND WALL STREET, THEY ARE THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
TELLING US OF THIS WILL BE GREAT
FOR AMERICA AND THE WORLD IF WE
INTEGRATE OUR ECONOMY WITH
CHINA.
IT WILL BE GREAT IF WE HAVE A
GLOBAL ECONOMY WHERE WE SEND
JOBS OVERSEAS.
TURNS OUT THEY’VE BEEN WRONG
ABOUT ALL OF THAT.
IT’S BEEN TERRIBLE FOR AMERICA
AND NOW WE ARE LIVING WITH THE
RESULTS SO I THINK THIS IS WHAT
WE ARE FINALLY WAKING UP TO, OR
THE D.C. ELITES ARE WAKING UP TO
THE WAGES OF THE BARGAIN THAT WE
HAVE STRUCK AND IT’S TIME TO
FUNDAMENTALLY RETHINK OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA AND THE
WORLD.
IT’S TIME TO START PUTTING
AMERICAN WORKERS AT THE FRONT
AND NOT KOWTOWING ANY LONGER TO
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: WE SEE THIS
PRIMARILY IN EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
TERMS.
PEOPLE IN LAB COATS GIVING
ADVICE, I’M NOT ATTACKING THEM.
BUT HOW DO YOU THINK CHINA SEES
THIS MOMENT?
WHAT ARE THE STAKES IN THEIR
VIEW?
>> THEY CLEARLY SEE IT AS A
STRATEGIC OPPORTUNITY, THE SAME
WAY THEY SEE EVERYTHING.
THEY WANT TO BE THE CENTRAL
POWER, THE DOMINANT WORLD POWER.
THEY HAVE A SAYING THAT THERE
CAN ONLY BE ONE SON IN THE SKY,
AND THEY INTENDED TO BE CHINA,
TO BE BEIJING.
THEY SEE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
ALONG THE WAY.
BUT HERE’S THE THING, THIS IS
ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE KNOWN
THIS FOR DECADES, THEY HAVE
KNOWN THAT PARTNERING WITH CHINA
IS DANGEROUS.
THEY KNOW THAT SENDING OUR
SUPPLY CHAINS OVERSEAS WAS WRONG
AND NOW WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CORRECT THOSE MISTAKES.
IT’S TIME THAT WE GO ALL IN ON
AMERICA RATHER THAN ALL IN ON
CHINA AND WE WILL HAVE THE
CHANCE TO DO THAT NOW.
>> Tucker: I HOPE SO.
WE CAN START BY CEASING THE
SUBSIDIZING OF THE EDUCATION.
I KNOW THIS IS OFF TOPIC BUT OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES,
ALMOST ALL OF WHICH ARE
SUPPORTED BY TAXPAYERS IN THE
END, EDUCATE AT A NET LOSS.
THE CHILDREN OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO DISPLACE US, WHY
ARE WE DOING THAT?
>> WE ALSO ALLOW THOSE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS TO TAKE
MONEY ALMOST DIRECTLY FROM THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT, THESE
CONFUCIUS INSTITUTES THAT ARE ON
CAMPUSES ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
DIRECTLY SUBSIDIZED BY BEIJING.
YOU MIGHT ASK WHY DO AMERICAN
CAMPUSES ALLOW THESE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT OUTPOSTS ON THEIR OWN
CAMPUSES, AND THE REASON IS THEY
GET PAID TO, IT’S LUCRATIVE.
WE GOT TO STOP THIS COZY DEALING
WITH BEIJING ON OUR CAMPUSES,
WITH OUR INTERNATIONAL TRADE
FROM OUR FINANCIAL INSTITUTION
AND OUR MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS.
IT’S TIME TO ACTUALLY PUT THE
AMERICAN WORKER AND AMERICAN
FAMILIES IN AMERICAN INTERESTS
FIRST.
IT’S TIME TO PUT THEM AT THE
FRONT.
THAT’S WHY I SAY, WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY NOW AND
WE NEED TO NOT MISS IT, TO
INVEST IN THIS COUNTRY AND GO
ALL IN ON THIS COUNTRY AND I
HOPE THAT WILL BE OUR FOCUS.
THIS PANDEMIC SHOULD MAKE CLEAR
TO US THAT IT’S AN URGENT,
URGENT NEED GOING FORWARD.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CLARITY AND I